- Hey guys, it's Justine.
And today we are checking out
two new speakers from Sony.
A huge thank you to Sony
for sponsoring this video
and giving me these to these check out.
This is the new Sony SRS-RA 5000
and this is the Sony SRS-RA 3000.
Now, obviously I'm such a huge Sony fan
because they basically
power my entire life
from cameras to headphones,
to lenses, to TVs
to now these new speakers.
Now I've been loving the introduction
of 360 reality audio in their headphones.
So I'm so excited to hear what
this sounds like in my home.
360 reality audio is available
on title nugs.net and Deezer.
And now, starting in April
360 reality audio content
can also be streamed on Amazon
music HD by using Alexa cast.
You can also do multi-room speakers.
So I can have both of these speakers
playing at the same time,
playing the same content
all throughout my house.
So let's get these unboxed
and check them out.
(techno sound playing)
- [Justine] The SRS RA 5000
features multi-room music.
The ability to connect wirelessly
to your TV, voice
control, sound calibration
and automatic sound
adjustment to make sure all
of the tracks are playing consistently.
Oh my goodness,
- like this is my color scheme.
- [Justine] This is it!
This is me!
This is me if I were a speaker.
360 reality audio
is one of the major features
of these speakers and it
allows you to experience music
all around you with
ambient room filling sound.
Now, even if your tracks
aren't 360 reality enabled
you'll still get that
immersive audio enhancement
using Sony's unique algorithm
to upscale your tracks.
This speaker has seven driver units
so you'll definitely be
able to hear a difference.
There's three speakers facing up,
three side speakers and a woofer
which will help flood the
entire room with sound.
- Okay, We've got our first one unboxed.
Let's open up the SRS-RA 3000
Look at you.
Oh, this is cool because
we have a different color.
- [Justine] The Sony SRS-RA 3000
shares lot of similar features
with the RA-5000.
While it is a bit smaller,
it has a beam tweeter
that produces sound waves
that overlap each other to form
an upwards facing wavefront.
The RA-3000 is also humidity resistance.
So you can use it safely
in a bathroom, kitchen
or any potentially humid environment.
- Oh, Whoa.
Okay.
- [Justine] I actually
loved this color as well.
So this is definitely gonna
match my kitchen aesthetic.
So let's look at these side by side.
- Obviously this is a much larger speaker
so you've already going to be
getting a much louder sound
but I feel like this
has a lot more benefits.
It also has a much smaller power cord.
I love the fact
that you can also wirelessly
connect these to your TV.
And I do have one of the Sony TVs
that I did a previous video on.
So it's kind of cool to have
this whole ecosystem that kind
of works together.
I cannot wait to hear
what these sound like
Let's go set them up.
(slow upbeat music)
(slow upbeat music continues)
- [SRS-RA 5000] Sound calibration start.
- [Justine] Oh.
(robotic sound)
- I think we're calibrated.
I have the Sony music
center app already installed
and this is what we're
going to use to calibrate
and sync this to my phone,
Much like syncing your headphones,
It's basically the same
thing that you're doing here.
I just opened the app and
it just, it just popped up.
Like it's already there.
Let's play our first song.
(deep bass music)
I love that it has the button on the side.
♪ I know you like ♪
Whoa.
♪ Just what you see ♪
♪ when I walk by you. ♪
♪ Take your time and you drown my world ♪
♪ with the look in your eyes. ♪
♪ Your smile is like ♪
(music continues playing)
- This sounds incredible.
- Okay, the hard thing about
doing these types of videos
when we're talking about
audio is you guys can't
actually experience what I'm experiencing
because you're hearing the
audio basically just off
of my microphone, but
what's incredible about
360 reality audio is
the fact that they are
able to really create this
incredible immersive experience
because they're designing these sounds
in a 3D space. It's an all
new way to create music
and it's really an all
new way to experience it.
Let me play another track.
(deep base song playing)
- Let's turn it all the way up.
(deep base music playing continues)
It's
so
loud.
Whoa.
Wow.
I feel like
I made a concert.
I haven't been to a concert
in over a year and a half.
(Rap song playing)
Foo Fighters
Foo Fighters 360 reality audio?
(rock music playing)
This is everything that I ever wanted.
(rock music playing continues)
- I'm slightly speechless
because I have a ton of smaller speakers
around my house, but
honestly, nothing has sounded
like this crisp and clear.
And it's amazing.
I also previously had
tested out playing some none
360 reality audio, but I
don't have clearance to
play those songs.
And it's incredible because
even though those songs aren't
specifically created with the 360 reality
audio technology, you can
easily turn this feature on
- [Justine} by hitting the music note
for instant immersive audio enhancement.
This is what allows the speaker to make
none 360 reality audio
tracks sound very similar
to a 360 reality audio experience.
- I love it, both of these speakers
have a 3.5 millimeter jacks.
So you could do audio input.
It has wifi capabilities and Bluetooth.
So you're able to just Bluetooth in
and I'm also able to use
my voice if I have a Google
or an Alexa enabled device,
I can say things like
Play tool in the living room.
(techno music plays)
I don't have clearance to play you
but I love.
I'll continue that track later.
I listened to so many different genres
of music and what's
really great about this
- [Justine] is it has an auto volumes.
We'll be able to consistently
keep those tracks
at a consistent level throughout
my listening experience.
- It's also really cool
because I'm able to wirelessly connect
my television to the speaker
- so I can have
- [Justine] an even more
incredible immersive experience
by watching TV
and using the speaker connected to it.
(slow beat sound playing)
My kitchen speaker is all set up
and like I was talking about before
- I can control this with my voice
using any Google or Amazon Alexa devices.
- [Justine] So play Taylor
Swift on kitchen speaker
- Shuffling songs by Taylor Swift
on Amazon music, playing
on kitchen speaker
- And to avoid a copyright strike
we're going to stop it right there,
but it's really great
because being able to use
my voice to control things
especially when I am in the kitchen
is amazing because I'm normally in here
cooking or causing some
kind of trouble fires.
This is, this one is
resistant to humidity.
This is something that you could put
either in your kitchen or in the bathroom.
So obviously this is now
my new kitchen companion.
I like that this is a smaller profile
but still has some
incredible sound quality.
So let's test this out.
(upbeat song playing)
- Whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
for being such a small speaker.
I'm shock.
(piano playing)
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh God,
I didn't mean to do that.
I push, I push something.
I love doing these types
of videos, but it's so hard
for you guys to actually experienced
what we experienced in real life.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
If you guys want to get more information
about the speakers that
we talked about today.
I will put all of the links
in the description below.
I am so excited about this new
addition to my Sony family.
I'll see you guys in the next video.
- Bye.
(slow beat music )